[Music]
yes disney theories are the best this
one ties together not just brave and
frozen but tangled too stick around
until the end to find out about
rapunzel's secret sister new to the
things hit that subscribe button and
never miss out don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up now let's see
exactly how brave is connected to frozen
i've allowed a quarter of lutefisk so we
have good feelings
just the outfit in the boots yeah disney
theories are half the fun of being a
disney fan we can't get enough of them
the original stories are incredible but
seeing new creative twists is super fun
whether a theory extends a story expands
a character or ties movies together
they're all just as fascinating disney
fans have no shortage of creativity it's
not hard to find a ton of theories on
any disney movie one fan came up with a
pretty detailed theory linking frozen
brave and tangled together it may seem
like a bit of a stretch but the
arguments are pretty good if you give it
a chance it makes a lot of sense there
are a ton of little details that support
the tie-ins in brave the four clans ding
wall mcguffin macintosh and dunbroch are
constantly locked in war for generations
they fought each other in endless
skirmishes over land resources and honor
it wasn't until an outside force united
the clans together invaders from rome
scandinavia and the north began to
attack the clans in their homelands they
united together with fergus as their
leader the clans defeated the foreign
invaders and formed the kingdom of
dunbroch fergus became their king and
his wife eleanor became their queen
reddit user the jarvie thinks they may
know at least one of the invading forces
part of their theory is that arendelle
the kingdom of frozen were outside
attackers king agnar of arendelle wears
quite a few medals this theory imagines
that he won them during the war against
the clans if that's true brave tingled
and frozen all take place in the same
time period the theory goes on to
analyze a layout of arendelle itself the
city is built more like a fort than a
medieval castle instead of a royal
palace sitting atop a hill with miles of
sprawling land around it it's right on a
cliff that makes it seem like it was
built to defend the harbor and house
ships it really does look more like a
naval base the city is surrounded by
impenetrable mountains that makes it a
great location for a military
installment if you're building a fort
you need to defend from invaders you
want it to be as difficult to access as
possible this layout makes less sense
for a residential area feudal economies
relied heavily on trade it would be
really difficult for anyone to get to
arendelle to trade from the outside
sailing in by ship is the only option
which is very expensive this would limit
who could trade with the kingdom if
arendelle was built as a fort and agnar
was its commander it would make sense
why he then became king if the city was
only founded recently that would also
explain why the castle has no pictures
of rulers before him he would be the
first king of arendelle oh look at that
i've been impaled the duke of weaseltown
also seems to have a lot of war medals
in this theory weaseltown and arendelle
were allies during the war if they
fought together against the clans this
would explain why they're close allies
with arendelle despite their cultural
differences weaseltown is a ruthless and
greedy land everyone is out for
themselves arendelle seems to have a
shared morality they are kind and
generous people something had to have
untied these two kingdoms together to
make them allies when ana's magical
powers are revealed the people of
arendelle most seem totally shocked and
caught off guard everyone but one person
that is the duke of weaselton the duke
of weaseltown reacts as if he's seen
magic before and he finds it threatening
it's possible that there was witchcraft
used in the war if he had a bad
experience with magic in the past that
would explain his aggressive reaction to
anna while everyone else is picking
their jaws up off the ground the duke is
ready to rally against her he's not the
only character who seems to had a past
run with magic anna developed a white
streak in her hair after she was
accidentally attacked with her sister's
power it's a really beautiful symbol of
her dangerous encounter queen eleanor
has a very similar white streak in her
hair it's even in the same location this
makes it seem like queen eleanor may
have had a similar experience to anna
most people in the clans don't seem to
believe in magic fergus is certainly
skeptical queen eleanor is a true
believer could that be because she's
seen magic firsthand merida's culture
and brave is distinct from that of
arendelle the clothing is highly
stylized in dunbroch everyone wears a
lot of traditional tartans as well as
fur we don't see a lot of fur in
arendelle it appears that even after the
war ended no friendship was formed
between arendelle and the clans in
corona however it's a different story
after rapunzel escapes from her tower
she sees a whole new side of her kingdom
she and eugene stop into a tavern called
the snuggly duckling at the tavern we
see people dressed more like members of
the four clans could scottish immigrants
move to corona after the war could
corona have been allies of dunbroch
there's a map shown at the end of
tangled with the sea serpent in the
north sea a very similar map is
displayed in brave the second map shows
the serpent in the south that could be a
huge clue that the films are related and
that the kingdoms aren't that far apart
well
i do like ducklings yay
there's future evidence that the three
films all take place in the same
universe when king agdar consults the
book to find out how to save anna
there's a clue in an illustration the
troll appears to be healing someone
dressed more like a person from the
clans than someone from arendelle the
director of frozen has confirmed the
link between his film and tangled anna
and elsa's parents were on their way to
a family wedding when their ship sank it
wasn't just any wedding it was that of
their cousin rapunzel to her fiance
eugene rapunzel and eugene also attended
the coronation of queen elsa the two
royal families are related it seems like
they hadn't been in contact for years
before being invited to rapunzel's
wedding fans even have theories as to
why that is one theory is that since
both elsa and rapunzel had magical
powers king agnar moved away to protect
elsa from being kidnapped like rapunzel
that's a pretty solid idea but we think
it's part of a larger picture the witch
and brave is hiding away in the woods in
exile elsa is told to hide her power no
matter what rapunzel's power wasn't
shunned by her family she was
desperately missed and her return was
celebrated this makes it seem like
corona has a much different attitude
toward magic could it be that magic is
frowned upon in arendelle could that
have something to do with the great war
queen eleanor has the white streak
implying she's been magically attacked
the duke of weaseltown seems to hate
magic and finds it an extreme threat
could agnar and his cousins in corona
have split over their loyalties in the
war could that split and the war itself
have been about each culture's view on
magic if all of that is true it would
explain why there is no mention of anna
elsa and rapunzel being cousins until
the coronation if their parents
generation of the family were estranged
over the war the younger members might
be ready to put differences aside after
the death of their parents and her
crowniness queen elsa would be smart to
make allies with her cousin in corona as
a new leader she would need all the
support she could get if that's any sign
of the rest of her reign she'll be a
great queen she's already ending feuds
and forming alliances if she restored
relations with corona she could probably
form a friendly tie to dunbroch ii what
an alliance that would be three kingdoms
all with powerful female leadership
there's another detail of the jarvis
theory that we can't help but love the
witch's cottage and brave is full of
bear carvings she's whittled herself a
little earthsign army she also creates a
transformation spell and chooses for her
target to turn into a bear she clearly
has a thing for the big brown animals in
frozen sven's outpost has some similar
motifs there are bears carved into the
counter some fans have argued that sven
is a good witch they didn't pull the
idea out of thin air frozen is based on
a book called the ice queen in the
original story sven shack is actually a
good witch's cottage could it be that
bears are a sacred symbol to the magic
users in the universe now that we've
established tons of connections between
all three films there's another huge
twist i don't want to get married i want
to stay single and let my hair flow in
the wind as i ride through the glen this
one is huge so get ready for a shock
some fans believe that rapunzel wasn't
corona's only princess some imagined she
had a little sister after rapunzel was
kidnapped her parents were heartbroken
they lived in pain for years when the
queen became pregnant again they were
consumed with fear they couldn't help
but be afraid that their second child
would disappear too they came up with a
plan to protect her the innocent baby
was sent away to live with her aunt and
uncle in arendelle here's where the
theory splits some fans believe elsa is
rapunzel's sister they both have
beautiful platinum blonde hair they both
have mysterious magical powers too since
none of their parents have such light
hair this could hold some water does
their blonde hair come from their
magical powers as soon as rapunzel loses
her powers her hair turns brown like her
mother's it does seem like their locks
are so light because of their powers
when the trolls ask elsa's father if she
was born with her powers or cursed he
stutters was that because he isn't her
real father so he wasn't at her birth
other fans have guessed that anna is
rapunzel's secret sister with her light
eyes and brown hair she looks a lot like
the queen of corona either way rapunzel
may have a sister out there that she's
just not getting to know if the secret
sister part of the theory hasn't taken
it far enough for you what if there was
one more step some fans think that baby
elsa wasn't sent to arendelle first
queen eleanor has the same exact white
streak in her hair that anna has could
it be because they were trusted with
little elsa first was queen eleanor hit
with her ice magic could that even be a
part of what started the war in the
first place this theory seems to get
more complicated by the second that's
part of what makes it so fun the
kingdoms of dunbroch arendelle and
corona are already entrancing they each
have a unique culture and beautiful
landscapes it's incredible to see how
carefully all three were connected by
the span theory having this new
perspective on the war against the clans
is pretty fun too this theory puts a
whole new spin on a ton of characters
sven might be a good witch theirs may be
the ultimate symbol of magic we learned
that elsa may be adopted how
mind-blowing is that is she the reason
queen eleanor and anna have matching
white highlights one of the most
interesting parts of this fan theory is
definitely the breakdown of arendelle's
layout we never noticed just how much
the city resembled a naval fort it
really does have the perfect location
for defense all of these connections
between brave and frozen are total eye
openers who knew just how much these two
films had in common the additional
tie-ins to tangled are like the icing on
the top of the theory cake there's no
way around it we're still reeling over
rapunzel having a secret sister we hope
this disney theory was as fascinating
for you as it was for us see you next
time
[Music]
you